bismillah alhamdulillah assalamu alaikum
which is a greeting of peace peace be
unto you thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Deen show today
we're going to be talking about the
verbatim Word of God which is the Quran
now you are intelligent enough to know
that there is only one God everything in
this universe is running according to
his will the Sun the moon all the
galaxies everything out there you don't
see other gods besides the One God
because if you did they'd be confusion
in the universe they'd be chaos but you
do not see this that's why this is a
testimony in itself that there's only
one God now this one God who loves us he
cares for us he provides the air that we
breathe gives us the food that we eat
and he wants to guide us so throughout
time he has sent messengers to tell us
how he wants us to live now these
messengers they were the way just like
during the time of Moses he was the way
teaching you the truth on how to get to
God and he was equipped with certain
signs wonders and miracles to prove to
establish that he was indeed a messenger
from the one God then we had Jesus who
was the way who was the truth
who was the light in a time when people
were in darkness he was the light
showing you teaching you how to get to
the one God Abraham Noah and the last
and final messenger the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him they were all teachers
instructing all the human beings on how
to worship the one God how to get close
to him and how to attain paradise now
they were given certain proofs and
evidences and today we're going to be
talking about the evidence that is a
living miracle to this day Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him he did
certains miracles during his time but we
have today the living miracle which is
as I said earlier the verbatim Word of
God which is a sign
for anybody who is honest and sincere
with himself if he comes at it with an
open heart and open mind has got to
guide him he will see that this is not
from a human being that this is indeed
from the crater so my next guess when I
come out is going to be establishing
some evidences to help those who are
sincere with themselves and with their
Creator to know like we know over 1.5
billion people all around the world that
this is indeed from the creator of the
heavens and everything instructional for
you thank you we'll be right back you
want to go nowhere
there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger maybe maybe it's just to break
the ice
dr. Sabir the dr. dauer assalamualaikum
waalaikumussalam well him to live
Accardo we've partnered up in the past
you've been on the Deen show you no
stranger to our viewers good to be here
and greetings to all the viewers peace
and blessings to all of you
assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullah we're
gonna be talking about something that's
very very exciting for us to talk about
is the quran it's nothing complicated to
figure out but you're gonna help
establish some of those evidences you're
going to help us tackle this topic so
this sincere person out there can come
to the realization as we have that this
book which was revealed over span of 23
years is indeed revelation from the
creator of the heavens and earth talk to
us about this Quran alright bismillah
ar-rahman ar-rahim in the name of Allah
the most beneficent the most merciful as
we all know that we as human beings we
are created by every being who is higher
than us who we muslims referred to as
allah and we know that this creator is a
loving creator who would like to guide
us so all throughout history
he has sent prophets and messengers it
says in chapter 16 of the quran verse
number 36 that it is Allah who has sent
messengers to all the nations and they
came with one truth worship God alone do
not worship His creation yes now to
certain messengers and prophets our
Creator he has given certain books
certain revelations one of those
revelations or the last revelation is
the Quran which was given to Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him about 1400
years ago now in the Quran Allah has
mentioned many many times that human
beings we should use our logic we should
use our mind we should ponder we should
think we should reflect so Islam is not
a faith of just blindly believing just
because of our culture
society friends is telling us to believe
in Islam wants us to use our mind and
stablish the evidence so since we must
him say that hold on is something going
off here you said some Arabic words
you're gonna have to kind of now you
said Islam and Muslims talk to us what's
this LA was Muslim you know they don't
understand some people how right the
world Allah Allah is the name of the one
true God the universal God it's the God
of the whole creation human beings
animals the universe
Sun Moon everyone in the Arabic language
we call him the name Allah Jesus Christ
peace be upon him in our album in the
Aramaic language he also used to call
God as Allah hah ah right
very important the word Islam means that
you're submitting yourself that the one
unseen creator submission to the Creator
is a lot trying to make sense now and
the person who submits is a Muslim hmm
alright so those are the three important
rooms for the benefit of the view these
concepts now they're going down easy to
digest go ahead continue please all
right so since since we have a book
which claims that it is from the Creator
Muslim since we are given a brain all
humanity humanities you know we are
given brains to think and ponder so we
just cannot blindly accept just because
our parents are telling us that this
book is from our Creator mm-hmm so we
have to establish some evidence for our
own sake and for the sake of the viewers
and the non-muslims who may not yet
believe that Quran is from Allah so in
this show inshallah God willing we are
going to provide some evidence some very
concrete evidence historical and
prophecies and scientific and you know
geological and all of those evidences to
prove that yes this book cannot be from
any other author except of the creator
himself so you're telling us that you're
gonna give some historical evidences
scientific some prophecies that they're
all in this book you're gonna give it to
us today in sha allah indeed okay i'm
sure they're excited to hear but before
we go
we raised up a book now and some people
are probably wondering a book the guide
just dropped his book from the sky did
he just give it how did it come to be a
book how do we just briefly because this
is a topic in itself but just so we get
this out of people's minds that they
don't from the start have some confusion
what do we mean when we're holding him a
book did it come like this explain this
for us
okay revelation came to different
prophets okay now those revelations we
have written down by human beings so
when the revelation of the Quran came by
our Creator he did not drop a book in
the lap of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him it came in the mind of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him the
revelation and he and why did his
companions who knew how to read and
write to compose a book that we see
right now which is the Quran but in the
presentation in sha Allah today we are
going to go much more deeper into the
very topic that you have mentioned how
did we have this book in the form of you
know between the two colors okay so talk
to us now let's go for the evidence
number one that you want to establish
what is the first piece of evidence that
you can give us to keep people tuned in
to this show now something that's gonna
want them to want more talk to us sure
so the number one claim that the Muslims
do do provide as an evidence is that the
Quran itself seis seis many many places
one of those places is in chapter 32
verse number 2 of the Quran it says that
the word says the revelation of this
book is from the Lord of the al-amin the
Lord of the universe so inside the the
the creators identified that he's
revealed it yes so that's very important
that is a point it's very important
point right so it says that the the
author of this book is Allah Himself the
creator himself but the non-muslim
viewers may be obviously saying okay
fine I could write a book and I could
say that this book is from God it does
not make it from God right so now we
have to provide additional evidence in
the time of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him Arabic language was at its
eloquence
and he speak mm-hmm all right you know
just like English language way back in
the 15th 16th century when Shakespeare
was alive yeah it was does the standards
was very high compared to you know some
of the language that you're speaking now
so in the time of Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him there used to be people who
used to be of such an high caliber in
Arabic language that they used to be
called as the Shakespear's of the order
times in english language we have one
Shakespeare in Arabic language in the
time of Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him they used to be literally you know
tens and hundreds of shakespeare's just
walking around in each single corner you
could meet meet one Shakespeare yeah the
the reason I'm bringing this topic is
dead Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
when he started to etre the verses of
the Quran that this is coming from from
the creator himself right
some people they begin to doubt yeah
they begin to doubt saying that how can
this person who did not knew how to read
and write who just grew up you know in
front of us
how come this person is bringing a book
and claiming that this book is from God
so to those people who are doubting the
Quran itself it makes some challenges
challenge it's very important that our
Creator is challenging the people who
are doubting that this book is from God
so there are multiple challenges which
King mm-hmm and these challenges are not
coming to just any layperson out there
in the ground right they're coming to
the people who are masters of their
language yes okay so in chapter 17 of
the Quran right chapter 17 verse number
88 of the Quran the creator of the
universe is mentioning in the Quran that
if all of humanity and the jinns jinns
is a different creation by the way if
all of humanity and the jinns were
gathered together to produce the
likeness of the horan they would never
be able to do it so this challenge came
to do make the non-believers ponder that
if you think that this book is coming
from a human being why don't you go and
sit down and equal compose something
which is similar or better than this
book try to collaborate everybody lawyer
Shakespeare's and all the people from
you know your heads the the most
intelligent among you try even with the
unseen gin like the would you say the
spirits come together and you can't do
it right so that was a very fascinating
yeah so that's a deep challenge that
came to the unbelievers of that time and
guess what there is not a single
evidence that they came together you
know having like a round conference
roundtable conference to compose a book
so Allah God you know just to just to
make them ponder he reduced the
challenge the Quran has 114 chapters in
there they call as the surahs chapters
okay so the initial challenge was to
compose a book 114 chapters now since
they were not able to do it Allah just
to mark them just to make them realize
it reduce the challenge okay he reduce
the challenge it says in the chapter 10
of the Quran that if you're not able to
produce the whole Quran produce only ten
chapters ten surahs' as eloquent full of
knowledge full of wisdom full of
prophecies scientific facts as the
Quranic chapters and guess what they did
not came together because they knew that
they're not able to accomplish the job
now we do believe and I want to just
tell me if this is one example of that
where if the creator of the heavens and
earth is saying bring something like it
so for those who are saying that this
might have come this could have come he
got it from other revelations from the
Bible from the Jews and the Christians
all that have to do was show that okay
look it's the same thing like he
plagiarized from someone else which if
we give a living example if you do look
into certain places in the Bible you
will see identical word-for-word some
pages that are identical to other pages
in the Bible like where Matthew or who
was it would copy from that to you
copied from was Italy copied from mark
identical word-for-word
many different paths so would this be
something of the challenge that you can
we're talking about well the challenge
was to
pose in Arabic language not in English
or Greek or any language in Arabic
language composed any composition which
is better in eloquence
in full of wisdom you know taking people
away from falsehood bringing them to you
know all the good things that they're
supposed to be doing yeah so they're
supposed to do that right there's the
challenge but guess what they're not
able to accomplish that so then God
reduced the challenge and it says in
chapter 10 of the Quran chapter 11 verse
number 13 of the Quran composed 10
verses I mean 10 chapters like the [ __ ]
ends chapter they did not do it right
then the challenge was reduced chapter 2
of the Quran verse number 23 and 24 it
says that if you're not able to compose
the full Quran or ten chapters produce
only one chapter they could do it
they're not able to do it but they're
you know that the magnitude of the
challenge is very you know mind-boggling
the Quran has 114 chapters it's a big
book by the way yeah it's a big book 114
chapters some chapters are very big
it has 286 verses in Chapter number two
and other chapters are small has only
three verses so the challenge was not to
compose a chapter as big as the biggest
of the chapter it could be the smallest
of the chapter which has only three
verses in there right so it's a mind
boggling challenge for all of humanity
and not just humanity all of jinns to
compose three simple sentences as the
Quranic sentences similar to the Quranic
sentences there's all they had to do if
they could have done that Islam would
have been abolished dismantle
disappeared way back 1400 years ago but
since we have Islam now it proves that
they've been not able to do it so there
is no historical evidence from both
Islamic on on Islamic sources that they
got together okay very important number
two some people may say that this is a
subjective challenge right that okay
fine if I cook a dish and if you cook a
dish
and if he asks someone to come in case
the dish right they may like my cooking
you're cooking somebody else's cooking
cooking so it could be subjective yes
it's arbitrary that you know depends on
the person's taste yeah I mean like a
poetry better than a second poetry and
you have a different taste but the
qur'anic challenge is not subjective
it's very important for the viewers for
to for them to realize in Arabic
language they are three different modes
in which a someone could compose
anything first you have the poetry
there's called the Bihar yes and poetry
is divided in Arabic language into 16
categories okay then you have the more
so more soul it's like the common speech
like what we are saying you know
speaking right now yeah okay then you
have the Sarge Sarge means it's a
combination of poetry and prose but it's
not a clear-cut into any one of these
categories okay so the challenge of the
Koran is that to compose something which
is similar or exceeding the Quran okay
the reason that the non-believers they
were you know are not able to come
together and compose something like the
Quran is they realized that anything
that they are going to compose is going
to fall into one of these three
categories the poetry the poetry yes
the prose or the combination of poetry
in the prose but guess what
for and this is a miracle of the Quran
by the way Quran does not fit into those
three categories all wrong no so an
example would be suppose if we call all
the engineers the best architects the
best builders in the world and and ask
them to build the best skyscraper the
best building the most you know
beautiful eloquent building anything
that they're going to build would be how
many dimensions three it has to be three
dimension right the most eloquence cuz
you know structure suppose if someone
composes or
build a sculpture or building which is
four dimensions right yeah somewhat
suppose if I bring this four dimension
structure no human being would be able
to you know replicate it likewise when
the Arabs of the time who are the most
eloquent in their language when they saw
the Quran the knew that it's it does not
fall into these three categories so her
an by its nature it's a fourth fifth
tenth dimensional structure mm-hmm
so that is what made them you know not
able to even come together to compose
the likeness of the Quran so we have the
language and the challenge we those are
two very strong points let's move on to
something else give us some more
evidence for the person now who's really
you got his attention okay very good job
so instead of the non-muslims right who
did not believe in the prophet of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him or
the oneness of the Creator and they used
to worship the pagan gods and Sun in the
moon in the creation all they had to do
was come together right to compose three
sentences but guess what since they were
not able to do that what did they
started to do they started to come and
physically torture the Muslims right
mm-hmm
and beyond that they fought 27 battles
with Muslims and in those barrels not
only not only the Muslims they suffered
even the non-muslims they suffered by
their property by their family by their
country and by their lives all the
bloodshed all the barrels could have
been avoided but by them composing three
simple sentences yes they did
mind-boggling right absolutely yeah
all right so there is the very first
challenge and the evidence that the
Quran cannot be from a human being it
has to be from the Creator they didn't
have to exert themselves that much just
bring up these three lines beat the
challenge and get it over with
yeah Aslam would be dismantled right
here and that challenge still stands by
the way there are 15 million Christians
whose native language is Arabic living
in the Arab lands yes this challenge is
even open for them and right now we have
the computers and the modern technology
the
could bring all of those things together
and they could get the help of the jinns
if they want to yeah all right so let's
move on to the next evidence for the
truth of the Quran yeah give us some
more now let's let's go down we're
almost out of time so we got the
challenge of the language and the
linguistic challenge now let's go on to
something else all right so there are
many many prophecies in the Quran
prophecies in the Quran one of those
eloquent prophecies is in chapter 15
verse number 9 in which allah subhana
allah is saying in a new nozzle Nazira
what in a loop la Hafiz une which means
it is Allah who has sent down this
message The Seeker this Quran and it is
Allah who is going to protect it mm-hmm
protection from any addition any
deletion any revision and it getting
lost so the Quran that we have today
right now in our hands is exactly the
same Quran word-for-word that was given
to Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
without any change without any change so
the way that happened you know really
quickly is that as soon as the verse
used to be revealed to Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him right he but the
miracle of Allah he is to memorize it
and in his lifetime he memorized the
whole book it's not a small book by the
way look at how many pages right it's a
big book he memorized the whole Quran
and his lifetime companions around him
tens and hundreds and thousands of them
they memorized the whole Quran that's
the second miracle people of all
generations they kept on memorizing the
heart and the kept on memorizing the
Quran up until the year 2009 without any
break breakage in any generation and
guess what their ten ten million people
living right now Muslims so memorize the
whole Quran so this is it's been
memorized as it was memorized back then
and it was passed down and we have it in
its original memorized like and recited
like it was back then
yes continuous chain of memorization and
there is no book no Bible Old Testament
New Testament the Hindu Vedas the
Buddhist any scripture or any secular
scripture for that matter who has which
has been memorized by that minute
people for that longer time tell us now
we have a few more minutes and we have
stairs so much to cover this time goes
by fast science this is the time now
where science is not like it was before
and tell us is there any things of
science mentioned in the Quran that
wasn't known back then but it's known
today and it's mentioned in the Quran
sure
very good very good see the Quran has
6,000 plus verses in there right and not
close to 500 of those verses they deal
with modern scientific facts okay not
theories not hypothesis modern
scientific facts 500 of them and guess
what none of them are contradicted by
the modern scientific you know
discoveries and inventions so just
imagine a human being
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
living in the seventh century did not
know how to read and write without any
telescope or my microscope or any
instruments that we are familiar with
coming up with scientific truths
okay so let's you know in maybe a couple
of minutes it says in the Quran chapter
21 verse number 30 don't the unbelievers
see that the heavens and the earth
they were joined together and it is
Allah who has made them asunder so that
speaks about the fact about the the Big
Bang the peridot the paradigm that we
all the scientists in the world that's
how they believed that the universe came
into existence a primordial mass
eventually explosion that explosion gave
rise to all the galaxies the Sun in the
moon and the whole world that the
invention in this dimension in the Koran
discovered just in the last century by
using our Hubble telescope and the red
ship and the blue ship and all of that a
person living there in the desert cannot
have done that it has about things about
embryology embryology all right
embryology means how when a fetus when a
baby develops inside the mother's womb
it describes in details many many places
in the Quran that from a very you know a
few cell stage how is the baby looks
like correct how the baby looks like and
how it develops and all of those things
and it's scientifically accurate in fact
there are many scientists living here
over day in age dr. Keith Moore dr.
maurice bucaille
dr. Marshall Johnson who whose books
that I have read in my medical science
by the way and they testify to the fact
that a human being cannot have done
those things it has to be coming from
God maurice bucaille says that Robert
Marshall says that and you know Keith
Moore says these are the specialists in
those fields they are specialists
rheology and medical doctors physicians
give us one more point we're we got to
go one more point and then we're gonna
have to do a part to talk to us one more
thing that's just like a very good
amazing chapter four of the Quran verse
number 82 it says that had this book
been from other besides other than the
Creator Allah you would have found many
contradiction in it right so if you
examine anyone anyone if you pick up the
Quran and you read the Quran you would
not find any contradiction
neither internal nor external no
contradiction when it comes to Quran in
science Quran in philosophy Quran and
you know the things that we are aware of
the things that we know of
so for Ana's free of contradiction a big
book written by a person who is not able
to read and write cannot have come with
that many verses without contradicting
himself for someone who wants to look
further into the science aspect or some
of these other miracles is there any
reading that you recommend that they do
any books in particular yeah there are
many books are one book that I would
recommend is the book by dr. maurice
bucaille
the Quran and the side the for the Bible
in the Quran in the light of history in
science and the website that I would
recommend is gain peace GaN peace pece
calm okay okay what we're gonna have to
we're gonna do a part two inshallah God
willing because we had so much to cover
so little time so we're going to
continue talking about the verbatim Word
of God
we're gonna cut out thank you for
helping us and we're gonna be back with
you in a few and we like to thank you
for coming to be with us this week on
the Dean show we're talking about the
verbatim Word of God
establishing evidences that this is
indeed from the creator of the heavens
and
so much to cover so little time we're
gonna come back and we're going to cover
part two on why this Quran can be from
no one other than the creator of the
heavens and earth we're gonna be right
back
you don't go nowhere here on the Deen
show with our guest dr. Sabeel muhammad
could not have known these facts about
human development in the seventh century
because most of them were not discovered
until the 20th century
that God transmitted through Mohammed
bits of his knowledge that we have only
discovered for ourselves in recent times
1400 years ago when the world was
immersed in darkness the Quran was
revealed which brought light to a
beleaguered world and whereas the
earlier books came with many scientific
mistakes due to the hand of man having
delved into them the Quran had none of
these contradictions the world thought
there could be no reconciliation between
religion and science but the Quran
mentioned many scientific facts in great
detail like how a human being developed
in the mother's womb and described other
scientific facts which amazed the
world's renowned scientists and
scientific community bismillah
alhamdulillah assalamualaikum welcome
back to the Deen show this week we're
talking we're sitting with the dr. Dawa
which I call um my good friend dr.
Sabeel and we're talking about the
verbatim word of god giving those people
out there who are sincere honest and
they want to know the truth giving them
some evidences that the Quran is indeed
the verbatim word of God and nobody else
is bringing dr. bilac continue this
topic assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam
tell America - we are peace and
blessings to all the viewers of the era
Salam alaikum warahmatullah alright we
have so much evidence here and there are
so many proves this is just something
just to scratch the surface just to get
the people excited but they can go on
there
and do some more investigating so in
part one we establish some evidences and
for each one of those you can talk for
hours now we're going to be in part two
we're going to be talking about the
possibilities of the person who is
naturally we don't want them to just
swallow anything blindly we want them to
use their mind to use the tools that God
Almighty has given them to judge to be
sincere to see like could this be from a
man or can this be from you know someone
in something in the creation that put
this together or is this indeed from the
Creator so some people have come up with
some arguments that possibly that he
copied it from previous scriptures like
the Bible what do you have to say about
this all right uh yes we have the Koran
appear who we Muslims there are 1.5
billion Muslims in the world and we all
claim that this is the book the author
of this book was no other than the
creator himself we all say that we
Muslims right now in the part 1 of the
show we have provided some evidence
right that it cannot be a human being it
has to be from God okay now in today's
show part number two we are going to
examine some of the possible authorships
that some non-muslims that they claim
that this book a fine since they don't
believe that this is from God they claim
that this book is either from copied
from the Bible or Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him he altered the Quran you
know from his own thoughts and
contemplating and all of their some
people say that this book was copied
from the Greeks and the Romans
literature and some say that you know I
know knows below god forbid this book is
coming from Satan
these are some of the arguments that you
hear from people indeed ok so we want to
knock all these out to make sure we
clear all this junk that's in the way
all right so that people can see the
truth for what it is all right so let's
take the number one possible authorship
of the Quran and many people especially
the Jews and the Christians they claim
that the book has been copied not in the
Bible ya know before we dwell on there
it's very important for us to realize
that prophet muhammad peace be upon him
it
says in Chapter seven of the Koran verse
number 157 and 158 that he is it was a
prophet a person who did not knew how to
read and write you know we all had
formal education we could read our names
we could read books we could read you
know internet and stuff yeah but Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him even if she
showed his name on the paper he's not
able to read his name right now so
number one he is was an illiterate
prophet did not had any education
number two suppose if he take up the
theory of was the Quran copied from the
Bible now in the time of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him the old the
Old Testament or the New Testament in
its complete form in Arabic language was
not available very important okay the
language of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him was for I mean Arabic right
what the Old Testament is in Hebrew the
New Testament in Greek yes right so for
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him even
if he had access to the Greek and the
Hebrew Bible
how would he able to read it so the very
first translation or the complete
translation of the Old Testament was
done in the 10th century okay so I don't
have access to did not access okay by a
scholar named saadia gaon he's the one
who made the translation around the 10th
century CE okay number two the
translation of all of the New Testament
was done in the year 1616 okay and in
the year 1671 rome it did the complete
translation of all the 66 books of the
Bible in Arabic language there is like
close to 1,000 years after Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him he was gone
okay now just because there are
similarities in the Bible and in the
Quran does not mean that one book copied
from the other book it is possible that
they both have common source right the
both have common source so what we
Muslims believe is that yes the
revelations came to previous prophets
prophet Jesus prophet Moses prophet
David and at the prophets peace be upon
them and some of the remnants of those
revelations are
still present in the old and the New
Testament and when the creator when he
sent the Quran he also mentioned some of
the stories of the previous prophets ok
so just because they're similarities
does not mean Quran plagiarized from the
Bible no they all have a common source
so when it comes to the Bible we see
that there are many similarities and I'm
just going to touch upon two
similarities because of the shortness of
time and then we will judge I will have
our dear viewers to judge yourself to
see if the Quran was copied from the
Bible number one there are similarities
in the story when it comes to the story
of Noah Noah lay Salaam right yes
prophet Noah peace be upon him the
prophet of the ark alright so in Genesis
in the book of Genesis in the Old
Testament the very first book chapter 7
verse number 11 it mentions that because
you know people were very evil in his
time the time of Prophet Noah God as a
punishment he sent rain for 40 days and
40 nights and the whole world was
submerged in water
yeah right and all of humanity anything
that breathes
in the whole world was destroyed except
the people and the beings the living
beings who were there in the ark yes
right so according to the Bible the
whole world was destroyed now quran also
mentions a similar story ok chapter
number 11 verse number 21 of the forend
it also mentions a similar story however
the quran says that it was the people of
Noah who were disbelievers who were
rejecting God who were doing evil they
were the ones who were destroyed hmm the
Quran says it was a local flood well not
the universe our universe Iran yeah
and is this something established now
historically historically it's
established archaeologists historians
they all have consensus that it was a
local flood in fact there is a very
famous book called the history the Bible
as history yeah okay by Weber Keller
remember he's the author of it and this
is what he has to say
that our key ology has not yet
established
a flood to the magnitude of the third
mention in the Bible but it has
stablished that there was a flood in the
Northwest region of portia engulfed in
400 miles times 100 miles that is the
area in which prophet Noah and his
people were living amazing so this is
one example I'm sure there I'm confident
that there are many more that you can
give but we have so little time talk
about the next point that he himself he
is the one behind he's the mastermind
behind this Quran all right so some
people okay so we have established the
fact that the Quran cannot have been
copied from the Bible or else the Quran
would have incorporated those same you
know quote-unquote mistakes that are
present in the Bible but how come the
Quran left all those mistakes and only
extracted the hunted things right yeah
unless it has to be coming from the
Creator indeed indeed right so now some
people claim that it was perfect
Muhammad peace be upon him who was the
author of the Quran and now it's very
important first of all he was a person
who was did not knew how to read and
write on the top of it he was given the
title of a Sadiq and Al Amin the most
honored and the most truthful person
right not just by the Muslims but also
by the non-muslims so the most honest
the best role model of a person in that
community is claiming that this book is
from God why would he be lying a person
lies a false prophet he or she lies
because of some ulterior gains for name
and fame and money and you know a power
and all of those things did he did he
have a hidden a bank account did he have
is it recorded that he had all you know
lived a lavish lifestyle that he had
these worldly things that might have to
support these accusations well actually
you know non-muslims since they did not
like the message of the oneness of God
right they wanted to worship all of
those idols they offered him they bribed
him actually that if you give up
preaching the oneness of God will give
you the best the most wealth will make
it
richest of the person yeah if you
desired that will give you that or if
you want if you're seeking after power
will make you the head of the state of
all of the Arab region yeah all will
give you the best women the best girls
for you to marry yeah but guess what if
false prophet would have taken up the
offer right become the head of the state
and whatever but Prophet Mohammed peace
be upon him since he was a true prophet
he rejected that offer and he said I'm
not going to take that offer even if
they bring the Sun in the moon in my
right and my left hand so the light that
he led led you know brother Eddie was in
life of very modest very humble life his
house was smaller than this studio you
know he had only like maybe just one or
two items in his house and there are
narrations there by his wives that
sometimes there was nothing for them to
eat for three days and three nights all
they had to do it was you know just some
dates and some water
so the Prophet Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he was much more richer okay
before he claimed prophethood then after
he claimed prophethood what could have
been the motive for that yeah it's
amazing is there anything in the Quran
now if someone is saying that look he's
the mastermind behind this obviously
someone's going to want to elevate
himself someone's going to want to put
themselves in the spotlight is there
anything in this verbatim Word of God
now that would support this is there the
calamity that struck him in his own
personal life with his wife dying or any
of these other personal situations are
they mentioned in there well there's a
very important point by the way see the
Quran has 6000 plus vs. it speaks about
you know many individuals many prophets
and all of death it speaks about some of
the common people many tragic tragedies
struck Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him right his wife the most beloved
wife's a teacher yeah at last peace be
upon her she passed away right there not
a mention not a mention about that but
what is mentioned is about the mother of
me Jesus peace be upon em hmm okay so if
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him if he
used to love his wife and his daughters
and his
so much and he had so many tragedies in
his life how come none of those things
are mentioned in there it's not
mentioning their yeah if he very you
know god forbid if false prophet he
would have mentioned and elevated and
honored and praised his family he did
not do it you didn't do it didn't do it
and it did not praised himself so much
to cover so little time the next
possibility that some skeptics might
bring up is that he got this from his
visiting with others in different tribes
other jews and christians people from
from the greeks from other methodologies
what we got to say about this all right
they buried some Jews and some
Christians okay not that many by the way
some scattered around the Middle Eastern
region okay the three important ones
that he had interaction with their
varaha okay
Baraka was the uncle of the first wife
of Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
her name was hot Eva yeah yeah peace be
upon her now he was a Christian what how
was a Christian so when the initial
revelation came the Prophet peace be
upon him he went to war aha
and he you know had some interaction
with him war aha confirmed that you are
a prophet and that you your people are
going to reject you just the way they
have rejected other people right now now
this work are that you're saying for
some people who are hearing this name
for the first time can you kind of give
more of who was this person
this person you used to be a pagan he
converted to Christianity alright so he
knew who Prophet what is prophethood he
knew what revelation is and he knew the
prophecies he knew the criteria to match
to be a prophet yeah not only that he
knew the prophecies mentioned in the old
and the New Testament about the coming
of a prophet okay yeah that could be a
different show but they are prophecies
in the new and the Old Testament about
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him so
after a few days after Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him was appointed as a
prophet varaha he passed away yeah
so the bottom line is what AHA was not
alive when the bulk of the Quran was
revealed and written down so how can he
being an author of the about Greek
writings or these other ancient sure so
some people do bring up the notion that
a prophet muhammad peace be upon him he
extracted the material especially the
scientific facts which are mentioned in
the quran right the urn has 6,000 plus
verses in there and no less than 500 of
them they deal with modern scientific
facts which has been confirmed by our
scientists to be as true yeah amazing
right now there are some scientific
truths and the greek-roman portion
Chinese Indian Egyptian writings yeah
there's no doubt about it okay that's a
fact that they do contain some
scientific truths
besides the scientific truths they also
contain an incorrect scientific
statements so now okay before I make
that statement suppose if not I'm not a
good student right and if I have to take
a final exam and if I'm sitting next to
a person who is a beep average student
if I'm going to plagiarize all of his
answers right at the end of the time at
the end of the exam am I going to get an
A grade suppose if this guy is getting a
big rate would I get an A grade if I
copied hundred percent from their person
no not at all right because along with
the right answers that he's you know
writing I'm also going to incorporate
the incorrect answers all right in the
same way even if for the sake of
argument that if Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him had a laptop computer with
all the knowledge of the ancient world
and that he knew how to read and write
okay for the sake of argument even then
if he had to extract the material how
did he only extract it
the truths from the scriptures and left
the falsehoods right unless he was a
prophet of Allah yeah unless he was a
prophet right because in those ancient
scriptures right they say that the Quran
I'm not the Quran the world some of them
used to say that the world was flat some
said that the world was flat floating on
the ocean some say that the world was
you know round in spherical so all of
many many different notions that they
had truth and falsehood how come the
Quran says in Chapter number seven
verse number three that the whole that
the world is spherical like a egg shape
not the shape of a hand egg but the
shape of an ostrich egg and that's how
the shape of the world is do we have any
reports that because obviously if you're
sitting with people and say you take
their work now that these people start
to see that you are people are starting
to admire your teachings and you're
getting some some publicity and you're
getting some attention they're gonna
come out say hey hey hey hey hold on I
taught you that do we have people
raising their hands and saying like no
no he got it for me do we have any
accounts of this in the life of prophet
muhammad salallahu salim peace and
blessings of Allah be upon him there was
not a single person not a single person
unbeliever who raised his hand and said
you know what you're saying in the Quran
I already knew it I taught you that I
taught you that or I knew it you know
it's it's a phone in this scripture none
no one raised their hand and accused a
prophet if they would have done it Islam
would have been dismantled so this is
are these are really just silly
arguments but obviously you know they're
worth touching upon because for the
sincere person he kind of sees through
this he's and and this just confirms
with him to continue looking into this
because indeed I mean it's overwhelming
the amount of evidence that proves that
this is indeed from the Creator there's
one more point some people say that this
is from the devil this is from and we in
Arabic we say Shaitaan yeah what are you
gonna say about this alright yeah that's
a even though you know for Muslims it
sounds like a very you know crazy
argument okay but for according to you
know you know some Christians and
whatever they do make that accusation by
the way but this is deep I mean if you
think about this because you're already
acknowledging that this is something
superhuman this is not cut it can't come
from a human being so you know yeah so
people okay people they want to deny
that the Quran is from God so they are
just going to one source or the other
source and Muslims we keep on destroying
all of those sources okay
now the source that they do say is that
the Quran you know god forbid is from
Satan
yes Satan was the author of the Quran
and guess what Satan is mentioned in the
Quran by the way yeah
each time Shaitaan or Satan is mentioned
is mentioned in a negative term very
important negative term each time it
mentioned it says don't believe in Satan
he's not God believe in God who is the
creator of the heavens and the earth
okay and it says on the top of it any
time that you're going to recite the
Quran I would to be let him in is
Shaitaan a regime that means I seek
refuge in Allah from the accursed Satan
all right
so Satan is being in a rebuke in the
Quran he is being called as an enemy of
humanity and he's been you know labeled
in very very negative way
Trump's anytime that he's been mentioned
so why would Satan would you know make
people go towards God and away from
himself does it make sense
there's against the the way Satan X so
for Satan to be the mastermind now this
is again a silly argument that if you'd
look at it you see this is dismantled
quickly because we as Muslims once who
submit to the will of God are seeking
refuge with the creator from the same
right and Satan was a jinn but if Jin's
are created beings and with that Satan
is not all-knowing it doesn't know the
past he doesn't know the future but
Quran has historical things of the past
and prophecies of the future so even if
Satan for the sake of argument was the
author it would not have been able to
come up with the historical facts and
the prophecies of the future and in in
in the verbatim would have got the Krahn
God Almighty is admonishing things that
the human being to stay away from
satanic things adultery fornication
gambling all the evil vices that would
obviously be more in line with teachings
of what Satan or the devil wants you to
do he wants you to break up ties of
kinship is that's a major sin to break
off ties of kinship he wants you to go
and cheat on your wife that's a major
sin in Islam he wants you to set up
God's besides the one guy that's
something I'll put you in a Hell forever
forever but it doesn't just doesn't fit
yeah I mean yeah that's for people to
ponder right I mean humanity
we are going through so many problems
right and Satan would be calling
humanity towards indulging in sin and
evil yeah Quran says that do not take
alcohol or intoxicants and intoxicants
is one of it says that it is a is the
handiwork of Satan yeah all right so
Islam is telling us to stay away from
things which are bad for your person and
bad for the society and calling to all
things which are good right obligation
to your parents to your family to
humanity at large to the neighbors and
to the needy and ultimately to submit to
one God there is the main message of the
Quran to submit to the one creator and
not to his creation may there be an idol
a human being a saint the Sun or the
moon and Satan would be calling towards
these things how come Satan if he where
the author he would be calling people to
the creation but not to the Creator but
the [ __ ] undoes the opposite so with
that the Satan cannot be the author of
the Quran so what where else do you go
now okay we've we've refuted some of the
arguments that someone who is possibly
just want to know the truth you say how
do I know that it didn't come from or
how do I know that he can take it from
about how do I know you just gave some
some good proofs that no this could not
have been from anyone other than the
Creator so where does a person go from
here now well the only option that is
left is that this Quran that we are that
we have in our hands right it cannot be
from a human being it cannot be from
Satan it cannot be extracted from the
Bible it cannot be from Satan or jinn or
any source so the only possibility which
is left right now is that this her an is
from a super human super about the
creation source and that source is the
creator himself who we Muslims call as
Allah now if there is the case it
becomes an obligation for each single
human being to find out what the Quran
is what is the message of the Quran how
can it help me and ultimately what how
it's going to help me in the hereafter
how could someone get a copy of the
verbatim Word of God
it's very easy right we would like to
give you a gift of the
I'm alright and this Quran is and it has
both Arabic and English in there but
some of you may not be able to read
Arabic so what we have done is we have
translated the Quran into 100 plus
languages so if anyone of you would like
to obtain a free copy of the Quran in
either Spanish or English language they
could contact a telephone number which
is 866 two is LOM 800 662 is lem if you
call the telephone number we'll be able
to send you a package that has a
translation of the Koran in there and it
has many many other goodies in there for
their benefit change Allah insha Allah
so tell us any advice for that person
who now he has grown up in a different
faith in Christianity Hinduism in the
roster in ISM and this isn't that ISM
and now you know he sees that by
watching his debt the evidence is
overwhelming that this you know this has
to be from God I mean what what could he
do to break through them barriers you
know that the the the Tippmann timidness
of now possibly you know maybe losing
some friends maybe you know being
associated with you know some of the bad
things that now the press and the media
are associating with Islam what advice
to give to that person who's just you
know needs that little extra
encouragement sure there's a very
relevant question and all human being
should ponder on that question okay we
all know that me you each single one of
us we are going to pass away one day in
this life of 6070 hundred years it's not
the only life that we have to live after
we pass away there would be a Day of
Resurrection our Creator is going to
resurrect that's back to life both in
body and our soul yeah and on that day
God is going to evaluate us there would
be day of judgment and he's going to ask
very two important question did you
believe in me alone or did you believe
in a human being or an idol or Sun Moon
or the creation and did you follow the
guidance and that guidance brother Eddie
and to all my viewers up there is found
in the Quran
in the Koran and in the life of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him who was the
last messenger and the last prophet sent
to guide humanity he was the mercy to
mankind so Islam as we have mentioned in
the initial part of the show
that means submission to the one creator
and all the prophets of God made that
big Adam or Noah or Moses and Jesus and
Ishmael and Isaac and Muhammad peace be
upon him if you examine the life of all
of them they did not used to worship a
human being or an image or an idol Sun
or the moon they all used to submit to
the one in sin creator that means by
definition they were following the
ideology of Islam submission to the
Creator and since they are submitting
there were all Muslims so in that sense
Islam is not a new faith it is the same
faith that was brought by all the
prophets so if a person would like to
embrace Islam they're not embracing a
new faith or a strange fate they are
embracing the same faith of all the
prophets of God okay that's very
important mm-hmm now we know that many
revelations came before the Quran but
unfortunately those revelations are not
preserved for us may that be the Old
Testament New Testament the Vedas and
anything else of that matter right ho
people claim to be as the Word of God
our life of eternity would be at stake
depending upon what choice that we make
in this world yes so you have maybe like
ten different books on the table correct
you have the Old Testament New Testament
and all the religious books of the world
along with the Koran now we have
provided our dear viewers enough
evidence for any thinking human being is
that how can the Quran which is over
here cannot be a the author cannot be
anyone besides Allah and it has not been
changed any other book besides the Quran
it has been changed yes okay so we
cannot stake our life of eternity in
something which is less than 100 percent
compared to the Quran which is 100
percent very important so what can Islam
offer for you my dear viewers very
important bye there are so many problems
which are going on in this world
we have a down economy yeah right people
homicide is rampant we are filling jail
after jail two point three million
people who are in the jails right
despite that fact and there are more
police officers despite all of those
facts the crime is not decreasing yeah
right the rapes are not decreasing
ninety thousand rapes in this were in
this country each year right assault and
guns and gains and divorce and homicides
and you know suicides solutions for all
of them are found in Islam in the Quran
in the final guidance that our Creator
has given to us it's all in the Quran
yes so not only Quran is calling us to
worship on God and wants to make our
life better in this world so we could
stay away from the problems and the and
the better part is it is calling us
towards all the good things in this
world being you know giving up cheating
and you know not lying being honest
fulfilling your obligation to your wife
and children and society or not making
you a better person society a better
person so it does away with all the
problems make society peace harmonious
okay but the best reward for a person
when braces Islam would be eternal
paradise in the hereafter paradise and
we've all wish ourselves our viewers
that we could all look into the Quran
ponder on the Quran read the Quran and
ultimately embrace the truth so we could
all be together in paradise
we're running out of time that's it
thank you for helping us to cover this
topic welcome inshallah we'll have you
back to cover another topic and we like
to thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Deen show you heard it
the evidence has been established and
it's very clear that this Quran could
not have come from anyone else other
than the creator of the heavens and the
earth at the end of the show you see a
number that you can call to get a free
copy and we hope that you are honest and
sincere enough of yourself ask the one
who created you to guide your heart to
the truth it's quite simple
she worshipped the one God you worship
Him alone you submit to him and you do
what he wants you to do on his terms and
that's it
and we hope to have you back here again
next time on the Dean show until then
assalamu alaikum peace be unto you eat
scone Italy everybody sleeping I arise
and ask a lot of thinking me Omar you
see all our you know all the sins I do I
turn to you to forgive my sin tomorrow
I'm you see for slave you don't my love
in Lord of the one runs away all the guy
me